To figure this out, let's have a look back at our picture from before.
We said that in a set formula each clause must be satisfied and set this is kind of similar
to the requirement that each city must be visited at least once.
This would suggest to add some additional vertices to the picture that represent clauses.
So let's say we have one vertex here that represents clause #1
and another vertex here for clause #2 and so on.
What we could say is that visiting this vertex here represent satisfying that clause and then of course,
we need to make sure that we can only visit the city here if the corresponding variable
or if one of the corresponding variables of that clause is satisfied in the right way.
What about a construction that looks like this--I connect the vertex that represents the clause
to this one here and I connect it to this vertex here and I connect it to this vertex here.
What I would like you to think about now is the following, there are 2^n shortest paths
between A and B if we do not regard this vertex here.
If we do not have clause 1 and I realize it's not the best name for that vertex but that's okay.
If we have to visit this vertex here, so it's now become part of our graph.
How many shortest paths from A to B do you have then that visit all vertices.
Is it still 2^n, is is 2^n⁺¹, or is it 2^n⁻¹.